20:18 is set to be the year the world
fully embraces the electric car will see
a global tipping point for drivers as
electric models start competing with
petrol and diesel cars head-to-head in
2018 for the first time we're going to
see that it's cheaper to buy an electric
car than a petrol or diesel car a byte
cheaper we mean the total cost of
ownership we're going to see
acceleration of the whole idea of cars
powered by electricity but will also be
confronted with the uncomfortable truth
about the impact of going electric
[Music]
[Music]
they've long been vaunted as the vehicle
of the future
oddly an electric car more like an
electric bath chair for a long time
electric cars had a reputation for being
like milk floats but from laughing stock
in the mid-1980s to rising stock today
electric cars have come of age new
technology means the range is much
better and some of these cars can
outperform the fastest supercars when it
comes to acceleration batteries are much
cheaper than better than they used to be
a better battery has been the holy grail
of the electric car makers for some time
[Music]
prices of batteries have more or less
harmed
since about 2012 in 2013 a Nissan Leaf
could travel about 120 kilometers now
cars are travelling 500 kilometers on a
single chart 2018 will be a tipping
point for the adoption of electric cars
because the more people who do it the
more other people will want to do it
there will be demand to build charging
points and other infrastructure for them
and that will make other people more
likely to buy electric cars so you get
this snowball of that companies are
clambering to take the lead with
billions in investments and promises to
make the switch it's very clear to us
that an electrified car is what
consumers want 2020 all of our new
mirrors will be electrified why are we
making electric cars to accelerate the
transition to sustainable transport but
it's pressure from governments that's
driving this push from the industry
we've seen Britain and France saying
you're not going to be able to buy a
purely fossil fuel car by 2040 we're
seeing cities like Paris Mexico City
Athens
Madrid saying they're not even going to
allow diesel cars into the city after
2025 we can expect to see more of these
sorts of tightening of the regulation
around fossil fuel cars coming in 2018
and it's an unlikely country that's
leading the pack all the action on
electric vehicles is happening in China
it wants to become a leader in the
production of electric vehicles just as
it is not a leader in the production of
the internal combustion engine in 2016
China brought more than 40 percent of
the world's electric cars China is very
well aware that pollution is a
hot-button issue politically socially
culturally and so if they can get more
electric vehicles onto the streets it
doesn't look as though they're doing
something to tackle this these fume free
cars will make our cities cleaner the
electric vehicle industry sells itself
to consumers as this futuristic
environmentally friendly means of
transport but uncomfortable truth lurk
behind the electric car revolution the
dirty secret of electric vehicles is
that often they're powered by
electricity that itself is produced by
dirty fuels such as coal
in order to be fully clean they need a
clean bread the napkin cost trillions of
dollars
the rise of electric cars will challenge
the world's thirst for oil it could
spark a global shift of power from
countries that have enjoyed the
influence that oil has bought the
control of oil has been terrific ly
important during the 20th century oils
get to become much less important if you
take the Middle East conflict tends to
increase when oil prices are low the
more we use electric vehicles the more
risk there is the instability across
oil-producing nations is going to
increase beyond oil attention will turn
to lithium electric car batteries which
rely on the mineral Cobalt
two thirds of the world's cobalt comes
from one country the Democratic Republic
of Congo Congo is not only one of the
world's poorest countries but it is also
a country which is renowned for violence
for for corruption for the use of of
child labor and for environmental
degradation demand for cobalt has
doubled over the past five years and is
set to triple by 2020 there's not nearly
as much attention on dirty cobalt as
there is on dirty oil or blood or oil or
blood diamonds but this could have
really besmirched the industry's
reputation almost before it gets going
but the electric car revolution is
coming after 2018 there will be no
turning back the combustion engine as we
know it was invented in the 1880s and
it's had a pretty good run there is
almost unstoppable momentum behind the
electric vehicle so eventually the
internal combustion engine will go when
it comes to the cars that most people
drive and electric cars really are the
future